oh
bon petit bonne nouvelle pour vous
puisque le sujet ce soir c'est
l'optimisme dans quelques minutes vous
pourrez aller boire un verre courage
alors quand on m'a proposé de venir
parler ce soir à ce tte dit que j'étais
super content et je me suis dit génial
moi aussi je pourrais faire comme tous
les autres speak earth aid g pouvoir
parler avec passion d'un sujet
passionnant vous mettez larmes aux yeux
vous transportez d'émotion et à la fin
je vous imaginez dans une
standing-ovation vibrante c'était
c'était parfait il y avait juste un tout
petit détail que j'avais un peu oublié
et que j'ai pas de jeu pas de passion
c'est un peu fâcheux quand on veut faire
un thème passionnant et quand on m'a
confirmé que que j'allais venir
je me suis dit en fait je vais leur
parler de ça du fait que page ait pas de
passion et que ça me pourrit la vie
depuis tellement longtemps que ça me
ferait un sujet de ted
en même temps c'est un sujet compliqué
qui d'entre vous peut me dire
honnêtement qu'il a enfin trouvé sa voie
enfin trouvé sa passion
pas foule les autres ça va vous le savez
bien
mon objectif ce soir ce serait que tous
ceux qui un peu comme moi ont galéré à
ne pas avoir de passion repartent avec
le sourire parce que le sourire moi je
les ai perdus pendant longtemps à
chercher une natation en fait pendant
des années en fait ben j'étais persuadé
que j'allais trouver moi aussi ma
passion et à chaque fois que je me
posais un peu des questions
existentielles je demandé autour de moi
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire et on me
sortez systématiquement ce conseil que
que vous connaissez tous quand vous à
tous forcément dit un jour tu as 4 bêta
passion est-ce que ce conseil vous a
déjà aidé en quoi que ce soit moi rien
alors du coup je suis bien sur amazon en
me disant peut-être que je pourrais
trouver des réponses dans un livre non
je suis allé chercher et j'ai trouvé
deux mille livres 2000 livres qui vous
explique comment trouver votre passion
forcément quand on voit deux mille
livres c'est qu'on se dit qu'il ya un
truc de vrai dans l'histoire de la
passion
forcément il commençait pas ces deux
mille livres qui vous lave le cerveau
c'est steve jobs vous vous rappelez qui
a en fait un peu inspirés les foules en
disant ce célèbre fleuri aux passions
quand le mec qui a créé apple te donne
un conseil forcément tu dis je vais
l'écouter
alors c'est ce que j'ai fait j'avais
écouté steve jobs puis j'ai commencé à
chercher ma passion moi aussi et j'ai
pas trouvé
alors j'ai commencé à me dire que
j'avais un truc de travers par rapport à
tous les gens qui qui réussissent vous
savez tous ces gens qui vous balancent
leur passion au visage ouais je suis
passionné de bande contente je suis
passionné de design
je suis passionné de tout et ces gens là
on a même l'impression que c'est
précisément parce qu'ils sont passionnés
qui réussissent et moi comme j'étais
passionné de rien je me suis dit que
j'avais raté ma vie
forcément or je voulais pas rater ma vie
donc j'ai commencé à chercher ma passion
comme un fou comme un soldat
là et merci
c'est devenu une obsession alors pour
essayer de trouver cette passion j'ai
expérimenté plein de choses j'ai monté
une entreprise
là je me suis dit ça y est j'ai trouvé
mon truc et puis non j'ai fait la
communication financière du consulting
je me suis dit ça j'ai mon truc ça y est
et puis non j'ai fait du parachutisme la
plongée des arts martiaux
à chaque fois je me suis dit ça y est
haha c'est bon j'ai mon truc est en fait
un nom à chaque fois alors j'ai écrit
des bouquins j'ai monté des boîtes à
chaque fois à chaque fois j'avais
vraiment l'impression que ça y est
j'avais trouvé mon truc moi aussi je
pouvais mettre à la face du monde ma
passion et que j'allais réussir et puis
en fait à chaque fois sa retombée comme
un soufflet est en fait ce problème là
c'est que à chaque fois je me suis dit
devant des clients mais qui suis-je
fondamentalement et professionnellement
ça commençait à me poser un petit souci
de cohérence
parce que on vit dans un monde qui aime
bien les experts un expert
il a une passion il exécute il rend dans
une case et moi je rentrais dans à peu
près aucune case à l inverse en fait on
me disait même que j'étais un
touche-à-tout quelqu'un de volage qui
manquait de focus inconsistant tue pas
si on l'a déjà dit ça ça pique
alors que tu passes tes journées étaient
nuit à essayer de trouver ce focus
ça m'a piqué 1 alors après quatre ans
cinq ans de transpiration intensive à me
demander quelle était ma passion j'ai
enfin eu la révélation
enfin j'ai pas de passion et j'en aurais
sans doute jamais et c'est pas grave et
si vous n'en avez pas non plus ce n'est
pas grave vous raterez pas votre vie
pour autant en revanche ce que j'ai
compris parce que j'ai expérimenté sait
qu'on peut parfaitement raté sa vie à
chercher une passion qui n'existe pas
c'est ce que j'ai fait et c'est ce que
je voudrais vous éviter ce soir en
essayant quelques minutes de vous donner
les quelques trucs que j'ai pu
comprendre pendant ses années de galère
à un des premiers d'une des premières
choses que j'ai que j'ai compris c'est
que en fait pour ceux qui sont un peu
paumé et qui cherchent leur truc on peut
voir la vie comme une grande feuille
blanche et sur cette feuille blanche
vous allez faire un dessin c'est un peu
votre dessin vous voyez les dessins pour
enfants ont fait des points pour relier
un peu les trucs comme ça en fait
imaginez que chaque point c'est une
expérience que vous avez eu une
expérience professionnelle en fait si
vous n'avez pas assez de points ça
donnera jamais une forme moi c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire au début j'ai
voulu relier des points pour trouver une
forme mais j'avais pas assez de points
donc je pouvais pas trouver de forme en
revanche si vous créer suffisamment de
points ça finira par donner une forme à
un moment donné donc ce que je voulais
vous dire par rapport à ça c'est
simplement de créer un maximum de points
tous les sens même si possible vous
verrez bien ensuite la forme que ça va
prendre
et tant qu'à faire si vous pouvez créer
des points dans tous les sens et soyez
inconsistant nanquette focus soyez
volage parce qu'il n'y a rien de plus
ennuyeux qu'une ligne droite la deuxième
chose j'ai réalisé c'est que cette
histoire de la passion
trouver sa passion c'est je crois le
conseil le plus stupide qui existe il
est stupide parce qu'ils reposent sur
une hypothèse
cette hypothèse c'est que on a tous dans
notre logiciel personnel très installé à
la naissance une passion elle est là et
puis il vous suffit de la trouvais
d'appuyer dessus et hop tout ira bien
c'est un conseil qui est stupide pour
deux raisons la première c'est que je
doute fort que on est tous avec une
passion installé dans notre logiciel
personnel et qu' il suffire il a trouvé
pour ensuite que tout allait bien je
suis pas très convaincu de sa ce qui
fait que comme moi si vous n'avez pas de
passion pré installés dès la naissance
ciane à qui ça arrive en est blond ça
leur arrive à bas comme moi vous allez
commencer à courir après rien fait
passer des années à courir après rien
c'est chiant la deuxième raison pour
laquelle cette hypothèse elle est
vicieuse c'est tout simplement
dès lors que vous commencez à être
intimement convaincu que quelque part
dans le temps et dans l'espace existe
votre vie passionnante
alors dès cet instant
ben le quotidien boire un café devient
absolument non passionnant j'ai vécu ces
sensations terrible et j'ai commencé à
détester chaque minute de ma vie non
passionnante dans le fantasme qu'un jour
tout serait tellement génial et le
problème c'est que quand on quand on est
comme ça a coincé dans cette dans cette
croyance que une passion nous attend
avec une vie passionnante nous attend en
dehors d'un inventaire beaucoup beaucoup
de temps à courir après une chimère or
moi je n'avais pas envie de perdre du
temps je n'ai pas envie de rater ma vie
parce que j'étais convaincu j'allais
rater ma vie est raté ma vie passée à
côté de ma vie c'est un sujet qui
m'angoisse particulièrement depuis que
j'ai peu près 17 ans 17 ans tout court
d'ailleurs puisque c'est à cette époque
que j'ai perdu ma mère en fait des
suites d'un cancer
alors je dis pas ça pour faire la minute
émotion dans le tijd
mais c'est pour vous dire que depuis
cette époque j'ai acquis cette espèce de
conscience un peu aiguë que la vie est
d'une affligeante brièveté en fait allé
très très brève
elle est même tellement bref que pour
expliquer les choses autrement on peut
considérer qu'on a tous en fait un stock
de temps sur les épaules et ce stock de
temps il est limité et le problème c'est
qu'on n'en connaît pas non plus la
quantité restante et vous pourrez jamais
jamais en refaire le plein ce qui est à
peu près aussi rassurant je trouve que
planifier un grand voyage avec sa
voiture sans avoir aucune idée naissance
qu'on embarque et quand on réalise ça un
peu fortement
alors on se rend compte d'une chose
toute bête mais c'est que sur cette
terre dans la vie qui est la vôtre dans
la vie qui est la mienne la ressource en
fait la plus précieuse qui soit c'est
pas le pétrole c'est pas l'heure c'est
le temps vous pourrez jamais jamais
racheté les 12 minutes qui vont un peu
débordé de ce talk jamais et vous
pourrez encore moins racheter des années
passées dans une vie qui vous ennuie
alors moi j'avais cette conscience aiguë
que je devais absolument optimiser mon
stock de temps ce que je sais pas
combien ils m'ont reste alors chaque
goutte de temps devait être optimisé
donc je voulais foncer foncer foncer
pour réussir on veut tous réussir mais
est-ce que vous êtes posé la question
ça veut dire quoi réussir là dessus en
réfléchissant un peu à ce sujet un peu
jour et nuit en fête
bah on découvre qu'il est encore un
piège je sais ce que je fais encore
tombé dedans c'est un peu une habitude
existentielle je pense ce piège c'est
qu'on confond généralement le prestige
avec la réussite
le prestige c'est une force qui est très
puissante
c'est une force qui est excessivement
puissante qui est définie par la société
par la culture parle de votre éducation
vos parents la télévision la pub n'est
pas par vous c'est un peu le côté obscur
ça peut vous obliger à travailler non
pas sur ce que vous
mais sur ce que vous aimeriez aimé par
exemple je peux me convaincre que j'ai
vraiment envie d'un plus gros salaire
pour acheter une plus grosse voiture
pour avoir une plus grosse maison alors
qu'en fait peut-être pas du tout ça me
rendra pas du tout du tout heureux et en
ce sens cette force très puissante moi
je la vois un peu comme un gros un gros
nez ont un gros nez on artificielle très
puissant et cette lumière
elle est tellement puissante en fait
qu'elle éclipse une autre lumière et
qu'elle vous aveugle une lumière qui à
mon sens est plus importante c'est votre
petite lumière à vous la vôtre on en a
tous une gmi vachement de temps à
comprendre que c'est sur cette lumière
là en fait qu'il faut se concentrer et
pas sur la lumière du prestige notamment
parce que si parfois la la lumière de la
réussite elle peut conduire au prestige
en revanche je suis assez convaincu que
jamais le prestige ne conduira à la
réussite parce que si c'est le cas alors
tous les gens riches et puissants de
cette terre seraient tous extrêmement
heureux je pense pas que ce soit ce
qu'on observe donc je me retrouver là
dans ma quête existentielle avec l'idée
que bombe à la passion c'est un piège
j'étais bien tombé dedans le prestige
c'est une illusion et donc j'avais
compris ce qu'il fallait c'est un fait
vraiment on se concentre sur la réussite
la question comment on réussit sa vie
c'est une question qui est très vaste
éminemment subjective mais je vais vous
poser un critère qui peut-être est
universelle et peut-être s'applique
autant avoue qu un mois ce critère c'est
pas votre salaire c'est pas la taille de
votre maison
c'est pas la taille de votre voiture le
critère d'une vie réussie pour moi c'est
l'ennui
puisque le temps est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux alors gaspiller son stock de
temps dans une vie qui vous ennuie
profondément je parle pas de l'ennui une
heure ou deux je parle de vrais ennuis
l'ennui structurel est gaspillé son
stock de temps dans une vie qui vous
ennuie tassée après comme je t'ai
dollars par la fenêtre
est-ce que vous
j'ai terrier de l'or par la fenêtre non
pourtant vous les connaissez comme moi
on voit un nombre de gens incroyables
qui sera bureau ou dans le métro qui ont
la tête de gens qui s'ennuie
profondément et ces gens là ils jettent
leurs stocks de temps par la fenêtre
comme ils jetteraient des diamants parce
qu'ils ont oublié que ce stock de temps
il est limité et nos amis anglo-saxons
avant de quitter l'europe en fait ils
ont un mot un mot qui à mon sens défini
l'exact inverse de l'ennui c'est le flou
vous connaissez ce mot le flou ce
sentiment merveilleux d'avoir les corps
et l'esprit alignés et de perdre la
notion du temps de perdre la notion de
l'espace vous connaissez très bien ce
sentiment
vous l'avez tous expérimentés à
plusieurs reprises vous savez quand
quand vous étiez gosse tous
et je suis assez convaincu que derrière
n'osèrent de grandes personnes derrière
nos costumes cravates nos maquillage
n'osèrent de responsables en fait se
cache quelqu'un qui est un expert en flo
qui a un doctorat en flo cette personne
c'est mieux quand j'étais minimes avant
de devenir grand et chauve et chiant
quand j'étais minot je passais tout mon
temps libre à dessiner à inventer des
histoires et je m'éclatais je me
régalais j'ai créé mes univers j'étais
complètement dedans toute la journée
vous en rappelez de sentiments comme il
est génial
il est fabuleux ce sentiment moi je
passais tout mon temps libre à faire ça
et puis les années ont passé et petit à
petit j'ai perdu mini lieu de vue parce
que je suis tombé dans le piège de la
passion et j'étais aveuglée par la
lumière du prestige
donc je le voyais plus et puis un jour
un peu par hasard c'est une autre
histoire
on m'a proposé d'écrire un bouquin dont
j'ai écrit un bouquin et j'ai écrit le
bouquin en 11 jours pendant les vacances
sans que personne ne me force et j'ai
adoré ça
j'ai retrouvé cette sensation de flou
que j'avais quand j'étais petit dans le
bouquin j'ai fait des dessins j'ai
raconté des histoires je me suis éclaté
j'ai fait des blagues partout que
l'éditeur a enlevé parce que c'était
trop nul et cette armée je me suis
éclatée comme un gamin et je vous
raconte ça parce que suite à ce bouquin
on a invité à faire des conférences et
dans ma vie j'avais jamais prévu de
faire des conférences mais je me suis
dit quand on a proposé
why not après tout ça me fera un petit
point en plus sur ma grande feuille de
la vie je verrai bien si ça m'aide à
trouver une forme donc gigi bigot et un
jour une école de commerce va proposer
une conférence un peu décalé sur
l'entrepreneuriat et j'avais monte il
dit carte blanche je vous laisse deviner
dès qu'on m'a dit ta carte blanche qui a
pris les commandes min woo
et je me suis éclatée comme un gamin à
faire cette conférence j'ai fait des
dessins dans tous les sens j'ai raconté
des blagues j'ai fait des histoires etc
je me suis éclatée et je me suis encore
plus éclatée en donnant cette conférence
et je me rappelle très bien de la
sensation que j'ai eue ce jour là où
j'étais en train de parler à mes
étudiants et je veux raconter une
histoire que j'avais inventé en leur
montrant des dessins que j'avais fait et
j'ai ressenti il à ce moment là le
sentiment d'alignement dont on parle
tant pis là ce moment là j'étais en
train de faire exactement ce que
j'aimais faire et ce que je voulais
faire avaler ce que je devais faire
c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important en fait parce que ce jour-là
j'avais un peu sur mes épaules mon mieux
quelque part et je pense en tout cas moi
j'ai vécu comme ça j'avais les yeux qui
brillaient donc ça a été vraiment une
expérience très important pour moi parce
que comme je le vis au quotidien en fait
je pense qu'il ya pas de hasard avec le
fait qu'aujourd'hui dans ma vie
professionnelle
la majeure partie de ce que je fais et
ce qui m'éclate le plus consiste
précisément à faire des conférences à
raconter des histoires et à faire des
dessins que je vis dans des slides
c'est ce qui m'éclate le plus en
revanche n'oubliez pas une chose avec
miou c'est comme une île où c'est un
gamin
légalement ils ont peur très facilement
et quand vous doutez que vous êtes
angoissé vous posez des questions de
responsabilité etc etc pour mini ou tout
ça c'est des monstres le doute
l'angoissé la peur c'est des monstres et
à chaque fois que minier où il voit un
monstre il disparaît dans sa caverne
avec votre petite flamme et on vous voit
plus et de nouveau la lumière du
prestige vous éblouit et vous aveugle
mois à chaque fois que je doute et que
j'angoisse c'est que j'ai peur qu'il
m'arrive d'un mini lui disparaît et je
crois que c'est votre devoir d'adultes
que de combattre ces monstres là pour
laisser mini vous existez lui va pas se
battre c'est un gamin c'est à vous de le
protéger parce que en retour lui va vous
protéger
donc je voudrais vous laisser avec deux
trois petites choses
la première s'est arrêté pour ceux qui
sont un peu paumé avec la passion arrêté
de suivre une passion qui n'existe pas
en dehors de vous cette passion vous
l'avez déjà en vous cette petite flamme
vous l'avez déjà en vous
en revanche si vous voulez la voir
commencer par éteindre la lumière du
prestige cette lumière
elle vous a valu elle nous aveugle elle
nous empêche de voir ce qui compte
vraiment c'est votre petite flamme c'est
ce que vous avez de plus beau à offrir
au monde qui en a bien besoin
et pour que cette petite flamme s'allume
il faut que quelqu'un qui sache l'allumé
reprennent un petit peu les commandes
ces mini ou laissez lui les commandes
tant que vous pouvez autant que vous
pouvez ce que lui c'est comme on l'a lu
mais lui il c'est parce qu'à chaque fois
que vous avez les yeux qui brillent
à chaque fois que min woo est dans les
parages
à chaque fois que vous avez la flamme
vos yeux resplendissent et ça personne
ne pourra l'ignorer bien longtemps merci